well that is easily fixable and that the
overwhelming majority of the American
people
and the overwhelming majority of the
Congress I think would want to be on the
side of fixing we want to get help to
people that need help there are lots of
hurting people in this country both
health related right now and economic
now and coming which also produces a
second wave of health public health
crises for people we want to get help to
people who need help a number of us are
very fiscally conservative and normally
spend a lot of time talking about total
price tags none of what we're here to
talk about today is about a price tag
we're talking about the fact that one of
the fundamental purposes of this bill is
to maintain the employee employer
relationship through the trough of the
recession that's arriving right now we
want to maintain the employee employer
relationship we want to celebrate
workers we want to celebrate the dignity
of work and this bill stated purpose is
to do that one of the fundamental things
this bill aims to do is to affirm that
employee-employer relationship and lots
of people pulling all-nighters for four
or five nights in a row now have been
building components of this bill which
try to strengthen and maintain that
employee-employer relationship
unfortunately there's a massive drafting
problem where when you look at the
interaction between some of the
different components of the bills
it looks like parts of other parts of
this bill would actually incentivize the
severing of the employee employer
relationship and that's what we aim to
stop and that's why we're working with
the Finance Committee staff right now to
draft an amendment that would solve this
problem
so that you wouldn't incentivize the
severing of the employee employer
relationship by having the employment
unemployment insurance provisions in
this actually lead to different outcomes
than would happen if people wanted to
try to maintain their current employer
that doesn't that matters because of the
importance of work the dignity of work
the long-term worker employer small
business relationship but it also
matters because we don't want to do
anything that would accelerate shortages
in critical supply chain and workforce
pathways inside some of the critical
industries in America and
critical industries in America I mean
health aids and I mean grocers and
people operating the takeout deli and
people do in local food delivery and
garbage men lots of the important
industries in America have median wages
which are lower than what would happen
under the unemployment benefits portion
of this bill and so we don't want to
actually accelerate the the severing of
that employee employer relationship
these guys are each gonna make some
comments and then we'll take questions
as well thanks Tim Scott I think buiness
ed said it well our goal is to help this
bill get to the finish line as fast as
possible I am in support of the
legislation this drafting error made me
pause for a moment the key to
understanding the drafting error is kind
of simple we can out of we cannot
encourage people to make more money and
unemployment than they do in employment
as an example in South Carolina the
average unemployment or the maximum
unemployment is about three hundred
twenty-six dollars a week so why do we
understand the legislation the 326 on
top of that would be $600 a week said
differently someone can make about 926
dollars a week the way that the
legislation is written the person who
makes less than that would make that
anyways so you would be able thus that a
person who makes $20 an hour times for
$800 a week could get about half of
their income up to 326 for South
Carolina and then on top of that they
would get an additional $600 so it
doesn't the legislation doesn't envision
the ability to have someone pick $10 an
hour or $15 hour or 20 dollars an hour
getting a maximum of a hundred percent
of their income this legislation would
not stop at a hundred percent of your
income this legislation would allow you
in unemployment to make more than you do
in employment we know that that is a
drafting error and we are simply
providing an amendment to fix that so
that you do not make more in
unemployment than you do when you're
working Lindsay will know in about an
hour
as to whether or not this is a drafting
error I hope they're right but I'm
concerned let me tell you why under this
proposal that they agreed to last night
on unemployment you would be making
twenty four dollars and seven cents an
hour in South Carolina there are a lot
of jobs in South Carolina that do not
pay twenty four dollars and seven cents
I've been one of the biggest advocates
of helping the unemployment insurance
system as part of a relief package the
maximum benefit as tens Tim said was
three hundred twenty-six dollars my goal
was to add some federal dollars to the
pot to get you back to what you were
making with the cap of six hundred
dollars which is an income of about
forty nine thousand dollars this bill
pays you more not to work than if you
were working very few people are going
to turn down a twenty four-hour dollar
deal not to work the work for fifteen
the problem for employers is that you've
been put out of business because the
containment policies that I think will
continue aggressively for a while what
do you tell an employee if you own a
restaurant or bar in Myrtle Beach or are
you gonna say let me put you on the
payroll let your salary of fifteen
dollars an hour or are you gonna say go
to the unemployment office and sign up
for unemployment get as much as you can
I know you want the money you need the
money and there'll be a job waiting on
you if you're a nurse aid making fifteen
or sixteen dollars an hour you're on the
front lines here a lot of doctors
offices are going to have to roll back
because elective surgery is no longer a
source of income for a bunch of doctors
so you're gonna have all these well
trained nurses they're gonna make twenty
four dollars an hour on unemployment
you're literally incentivizing taking
people out of the workforce at a time
when we need critical infrastructure
supplied with workers if this is not a
drafting error
then it's the worst idea I've seen in a
long time and I sing a lot given the
fact we're in Washington to my
Democratic colleagues I have been one of
your strongest supporters for upping
unemployment insurance but I never in my
wildest dream believed that we would
incentivize people to stop working to
take unemployment by increasing
unemployment wages to $24 an hour
you want to destroy what's left of the
economy pass it the way it's written if
you want to help people give them their
wages but don't pay him more not to work
so I come at this as somebody was sort
of some some businesses and something
became large businesses also come out of
it from the standpoint of individual
just finished this time as governor
about 15 months ago and my time as
governor we focused on how could we get
people off unemployment by getting them
a job and we're able to do that we added
in eight years 1.7 million jobs we're
down to 61 thousand people on
unemployment when I left office so as
this happened I was very supportive of
helping workers they don't have a job on
top of the gig workers the people that
getting tips and also using our existing
unemployment system because it's the
fastest way to make sure we have a
system and the money gets out there so
I've been very supportive now we have a
virus that we know a lot of people can't
work for a variety of reasons some
because government sets it up because
others because economies is hurt so
we've got to help them but the moment we
can go back to work we cannot create an
incentive for people to say I don't need
to come back to work because I can do
better someplace else these employers
are gonna need these workers to rebuild
this economy so we cannot be paying
people more money on unemployment with
it than what they would get paid in
their job so I'm very supportive of this
amendment it's it's the right thing to
do I know we still have a lot of work to
do to get this kernel virus behind us
but the moment that happens that we can
reopen this economy we have got to get
people back to work
so we can rebuild this economy and it's
it's like what Tim said people want to
work but don't create that wrong
incentive and your if we do we're gonna
hurt a lot of businesses and a lot of
families in this country so if this has
not changed at all are you gonna force
the Senate to go through all the
procedural steps to get to a final vote
I am very hopeful that we will get this
done very quickly I think the American
people need the resources in this bill
but but let me just reinforce why this
drafting error I hope is so important I
know some disagree with that but but I
like to do math and sometimes I do it
kind of fast but let me just be simple
with it so in making 15 dollars an hour
in South Carolina working 40 hours a
week makes 600 dollars if you're
unemployed you can get up to three
hundred twenty-six dollars you get half
your income so that six hundred dollar
wage now becomes three hundred in
unemployment what the federal government
does is it comes in and puts six in it
on top of that three hundred so now
instead of making six hundred when you
were working you're now making nine
hundred not working how long do you stay
in unemployment if you're making fifty
percent more than you were working the
answer 16 weeks we believe I hope that
this was an actual error this bill needs
to be done without any question I think
we can get it done here today and I
believe that we'll have an amendment I
pray and just pick up flowers
I'm hoping it is but we'll know in a
little bit because the Democrats will
say yeah you're right let's fix that and
we should know about the time you write
your stories and this gets out so so
here's here's the point for me I think
we've done absolutely the worst thing we
could do to stabilize the economy we
have incentivized people not to go to
back to work that is just I just can't
imagine the effect in South Carolina and
other
places when you realize you're getting
$24 an hour on unemployment so every
employer in the state has to compete
against a $24 an hour of minimum minimum
wage now I guess and in the smart thing
to make people whole up to about $50,000
and aggressively contained the disease
and get the economy open as soon as we
can that's the smart thing so is the fix
either is a drafting fixer as an
amendment to cap this at a hundred
percent of your income that's the the
American people do not think you should
get paid more money to not work than to
work and the American people and the
stated purposes of this bill are to
maintain the employer-employee
relationship America it's gonna come out
of this we're gonna beat the virus and
the economy is gonna recover but we want
American families to be thriving again
in six and nine months not years down
the road and if we do something now that
says the new baseline American
assumption is the government should
actually say this proposition is true we
want people to get more money to not
work than to work the American people
don't want that to happen and so I hear
that a lot of people would like to have
the fight about what happened on this
night versus that night in the
negotiating room
I think the charitable desire some of us
have is to say listen this is an
unprecedented time the pace of writing
this bill is clunky and stinky and messy
in lots of ways
let's start with the charitable
assumption that the interaction of the
different components of this bill just
weren't well thought out enough because
the thesis we should debate is do you
want to affirm unemployment response and
results and salary and wages as greater
than work no the American people don't
want that but do you understand how bad
the optics are to have probably the
wealthiest person in the Senate
potentially holding up this bill over a
couple of hundred bucks for some of the
poorest people in this country
so here so so here here's what I care
about I want to make sure that our small
businesses all of our businesses
including our hospitals our nursing
homes everybody can make sure people
want to come to work and I also want to
make sure which I in the bill that does
it you have an unemployment system in
the states that work and we need to
continue to work that and we have a
supplement to it because I get everybody
in the room everybody in the country
wishes they had Rick Scott's bank
account I get it but if you go to any
coffee shop in Nebraska you go to Omaha
you go to Lincoln we have 93 counties
you go to small towns and you walk into
the coffee shop and you say do we as the
people think what America wants to do is
say let's have the federal government
build a program that says we want to
incentivize severing people's work
relationship hell no people believe in
work work has dignity work gives us
purpose work is how we provide for our
families work is how we love our
neighbors we want to affirm the worker
in America working people in America
don't want a government that comes in
and says actually you know people in DC
know better than you and it'd be better
to sever your employment relationship
nobody wants that
so how did this happen we're on the
phone today getting great we're all on
the phone and I asked a question how
much is the unemployment benefit from
the federal government $600 I said okay
do you okay so ask the question that's
$600 okay what happens with that $600 so
if you're working for a small business
and your cook and you're making $40,000
the question is are you eligible for
unemployment because if you are you're
going to go and make more money and they
can't keep you on the payroll
so here's it's not about Rick or me or
anybody else we got to create a
sustainable system this pandemic is
coming back in the fall we need to
create pandemic systems on unemployment
that are sustainable so if you believe
that why not fix it now why not say in
perpetuity dealing with pandemics today
and tomorrow
you can get up to your salary no more
because this won't end in four months
it's probably gonna go on a lot longer
if this change is not made you would
require the full cloture clocks although
when I see the game
Gamecocks lanyard on you it feels like
you're too much of a homer for these
guys we're not trying to talk process at
this point we're just admitting that
over the course of the last four or five
days a lot of well-meaning people again
this bill is way too big for any
legislation that I desire but America is
in an urgent moment so there's a lot of
necessary urgent stuff that should move
urgently and yet the interaction among a
different a bunch of different
components of the bill has led to an
outcome that is quite different than a
lot of people stated when the task
forces were working 36 hours ago which
is what we're trying to do is maintain
we're trying to deal with the public
health issues we want to deal with the
VEX Steve Daines Manhattan Project for
vaccine acceleration there are critical
public health issues in this but at the
economic level of trying to provide
relief for the American people going
into the coronavirus recession the
stated purpose is to maintain employer
employee relationships and when
Republican senators were on a conference
call for 92 minutes this morning a lot
of us learned for the first time that an
assurance we've been given in other
settings maybe wasn't so and that
assurance was that you wouldn't actually
fail to cap this such that you'd be
accidentally incentivizing unemployment
and the severing of that employee
employer relationship that's what we
don't want that thanks a lot
let me just talk about myself what's the
most responsible thing to do is to fix
it now because the problems going to be
around for a while it's more responsible
to make sure that an unemployment
insurance setting you don't get more
than you actually make because that does
incentivize people to leave their
employment I'd like a vote on that I
think hopefully the body could come
together what's really irresponsible is
to create an aid package that
disincentivize people from staying in
the workforce in areas that we need it's
hard to compete against $24 an hour
so all I'm saying and I've been a big
champion of unemployment insurance is
let's just make sure we make people
whole let's don't increase their salary
because we can't afford to do that and
you don't want to server that an
employer employee relationship I think
the most responsible thing to do is fix
this now